all right as mentioned I was on Joe
Rogan yesterday actually I was on his
show last week but the episode I heard
yesterday and it was a it was great to
appear on the show it was on or it was
surreal surreal too because I I think I
you I started listening to Joe Rogan's
podcast
uh I don't know eight eight or nine
years ago maybe
and it was a I thought really good
conversation the first half of which
about 90 minutes was dedicated to uh the
film what is a woman and issues
surrounding it lots of Clips are
circulating from that part of the
conversation or you could watch the
whole episode which is what I'd
recommend on Spotify
but I wanted to play this one moment in
particular was interesting uh in my in
my biased opinion in my humble opinion I
thought this was an interesting moment
when we talked about the ways that
narcissism drives gender ideology and
this is a point that Joe Rogan brought
up and made and then I you know said my
piece and here's that
you're giving them an opportunity to be
special and to get special treatment
without any special act they haven't
done anything that warrants that
unique Behavior yeah I think it's a
really important point I think I think
that's that's actually so much of this
that and and people don't notice it but
a lot of this is uh is just it's just
standard narcissism yes especially you
listen to these you know why is this so
common among celebrities now all the
celebrities have have trans kids and
they're coming out as non-binary and
whatever else and then you listen to
like Demi Lovato whoever and you listen
to them explain why they're they them
it's always well I just uh I I just I
don't identify with these labels I'm
beyond that I'm above that it's like
these labels were good enough for
billions of humans before you but it's
not good enough for you that you can't
find yourself there but but all these
other billions of human beings it was
fine they had no problem but you're so
special that we need to change the rules
of the English language for you
specifically it's it's incredibly
egotistical it's bizarre it's like if
you feel that you're different than
everyone else
you're still a female you're just a
different human being who happens to be
a female if you're so unique go prove it
with your actions prove it with your
work prove it out there in the world but
to demand this very special attention
and that's what we give people like if
you give people that thing today they'll
tell that there's groups of people that
will tell you you're amazing you're
incredible you're beautiful you're brave
it gives them positive affirmation for
making these decisions
it's also it's also a part of what
you're describing is personality right I
mean it so if you're saying I'm a I'm a
female but I don't identify with girly
things and I don't like the color pink
and whatever
okay that's your personality and it's
fine there are many ways to be a woman
there are many ways to be a man there's
like almost infinite ways of doing it
because each man and woman has their own
personality their own perspective of the
world and that's fine so I think that
what I'm expressing is more the kind of
traditional ideas much more uh expansive
because it allows you as a man to just
you know be be who you are you're still
a man but be who you are the idea now is
that if you're well if you're a man but
you
um you have interests or ideas that fall
outside of the standard Norm now you
lose your manhood you're actually a
woman so they're actually reinforcing
the gender binary while while trying to
destroy it at the same time which is
interesting but I think most of what
they're
trying to describe is actually just
personality and now we have this
situation where you know you could have
a person who has five different genders
and six sexual orientations but no
personality because their personality
has been
subsumed by all of these labels it
categorized and labeled and everything
and and it's uh it's really strange
this is really good to hear uh I'm not
talking about my part that was really
good to hear from me now it's good it's
I can't emphasize enough how great it is
to hear from somebody like Joe Rogan
with his audience
I could go out there and make the case
and talk about these things and I will
and I do and I hope that I can have some
effect but uh it you know Joe Rogan who
the left to try to try to sort of brand
him as this right-wing extremist
fundamentalist which of course is
couldn't be further from the truth as
we'll fight as we'll see in the next
clip we're going to play but um
that's obviously not what he who he is
and what he is and he has a you know me
he's just he's like a mainstream guy in
a lot of ways and he has a mainstream
audience
and here he is identifying the truth
which is that gender ideology is rooted
in narcissism it's rooted in
self-obsession
um and a lot of it
is is you know born from this
desire that people have to you know not
be like everybody else
to just be kind of a normal person seems
boring and it's uh beneath them and so
it's their vanity that says that no that
you know I because
you only have access to your own inner
experience
obviously you don't have access to
anybody else's
and so if you have your inner experience
and you just assume so if you're a man
having an inner experience
like how could you even say that well
this is not the inner experience that a
man is supposed to have how do you know
that
you you only have you're a man and this
is your inner experience and so and
you've only ever experienced the inner
experience of one man which is yourself
so how do you know what are you
comparing it to
I think a lot of it there's mental
illness wrapped up in this as well there
are other factors but in many cases
especially with the older people
especially with celebrities as we said
it's just the Assumption it's the
vanity-based assumption
that whatever they're feeling must be
more profound much must be very
different from what other people
experience and so they can't make do
with the labels that billions of people
before them have made do with
now the second half of the interview
became a debate about gay marriage and I
wasn't expecting really that we would
talk about that issue but it came up and
that's how things developed and I was
happy to talk about it
um it is of course a you know it's a
it's a
relatively high pressure situation in
front of a very large audience debating
a guy who on this issue anyway is
diametrically opposed to my view
and uh I think going into a situation
like this it's important first of all to
you know you don't want to get defensive
or combative there are occasions where
being combative and taking that stance
is appropriate and as you know I'm more
than happy to
to you know approach something that way
if it calls for it but talking to a guy
like Joe Rogan an environment like that
it's going to hurt your cause more than
help it if you seem to be getting sort
of like defensive and angry so you don't
want to you don't want to take that
approach you also don't want to get lost
in the weeds and I know I'm always
harping on this but this is a mistake I
see people make all the time getting
lost in the weeds debating 100 different
side topics tangentially connected to
the main one and that's what can so how
so often happen on a topic like this if
you talk about it especially for as long
as we did we went on about it for like
an hour
and then of course the final mistake
that conservatives can often make when
it comes to this issue in particular
which is marriage uh the the mistake
they can make was just to fold and run
away and not want to talk about it at
all and or even to suddenly adopt the
opposite view in order to get along and
seem cool in front of the new audience
so obviously I wasn't going to do that
um the goal then is to try to calmly lay
out a defensive marriage in a clear and
simple and firm way
that's what I attempted to do anyway
we'll play this club it's kind of long
it's about three minutes uh as I said
this is from an I don't know an 80
minute
back and forth on this topic that was
that took up basically the second half
of the podcast
and you can go and watch the whole thing
if you want but I think this gives us a
pretty good uh Taste of of what it was
let's watch it
what if any negative aspects would there
be to people doing that if they're gay
well the issue is that
from my perspective and from their
perspective of most human societies that
have existed
in history
is that marriage is
the the context in which the the
procreative union occurs marriage is the
foundation for the family
um it is uh it's something that is
reserved for that because the male
female Union has this capacity to create
life
whereas no other Union has that capacity
and so it's it's it is a different kind
of thing and it makes sense to call it
something different it's like if you
know if if if Human Society were to
collapse overnight and we all woke up
with an Amnesia and didn't remember
anything about what happened before and
and we're rebuilding Society from
scratch and we look around and we see
that oh there are some couplings over
here that have this weird habit of
creating people and there are other
couplings where there are no people
being created
we would probably call that something
different it's a different kind of thing
it's also more important to society like
Society needs that you're you're going
to keep Society going because you're
creating people
um and that's what marriage was it was
the it was the context
for that procreative Union but what
about gay couples who get surrogate
parents to carry their children or who
adopt children that's very common
yeah it's it's common but that's not the
union itself is not creating
but it's a man-made institution we've
decided that we should involve the law
and to join a male and a female who
create a family like why would that be
mutually exclusive why would that why
would that not apply to a gay couple
well again part of it is it's a it's a
matter of definitions so it's a little
bit like the what is a woman question
it's like what is What is marriage I
mean I I
but doesn't that seem like an easier one
like two people love each other this is
my life partner this is the person I
want to be with so the way I die Let's
Get Married everybody is Happy everybody
celebrates what just two people why just
two people
why why only two people with
heterosexuals because that's not it was
on the case well because only two people
can create another person you know
um no you could have another person
involved and they can have your kid too
I mean isn't that what the Mormons did
yeah but only but only two people can
actually create
two people at a time right right exactly
okay
um and that yeah that's one of the
reasons why I would also you know if we
want to call it heterosexual uh polygamy
I'm not a proponent of that because
you know when when two people create
another person the person the child that
they've created now needs and deserves
and has a right to
um be raised in a in a stable
environment with a with a with a mom and
a dad who are living together in the
house that's what we should Endeavor as
a society to provide every uh child and
children need
they need both a child needs a mom and a
dad you know going online without
expressvpn it's like changing uh like
changing your clothes with the window
open you might not you might not be seen
maybe not but why would you give anyone
the chance to invade your privacy when
you go online without a VPN internet
service providers can see every single
website you visit what's more they can
legally sell that information to ad
companies and Tech Giants without your
consent that's why I use expressvpn
expressvpn hides my online activity from
internet service providers my identity
is um is made Anonymous and my data is
encrypted for maximum protection if it
sounds complicated it really isn't all I
have to do is fire up the app and click
one button and uh that's it I'm free to
roam the internet without any prying
eyes expressvpn works on all devices
including phones laptops routers so that
everyone who shares your Wi-Fi can be
protected secure your online activity
today by visiting expressvpn.com Walsh
that's
expresvpn.com Walsh to get an extra
three months free of expressvpn again
that's
expressvpn.com Walsh you know one thing
that kept coming up over the course of
the of the following hour was the
question of what harm
is caused by gay marriage you know he
Revisited this this point uh asked the
question several different times
how does it harm anyone to expand the
definition of marriage
and again on that point you could go
many different directions potentially
and there there are a lot of weeds you
could get lost in but from my experience
talking about issues like this in
hostile environments not that Joe Rogan
was hostile to me personally I just mean
in in you know in an environment where
people are opposed to what you're saying
and in that kind of environment you want
to focus on the strongest points and
again not not get lost
which I see people do all the time and
so I tried to convey that the primary
harm caused by expanding marriage
is to make it meaningless to make it
irrelevant
um and thus to make the institution
itself Irrelevant in people's eyes
which as I pointed out later on in the
conversation where we are seeing that
play out right now
you know we're seeing people giving up
on marriage marriage rates are declining
the the age of first marriage is going
up because a few or few people are
getting married or it's not a priority
to them and so they're waiting uh longer
to get married
and because they they see it as uh as
you know not an important thing it's
basically irrelevant
in a funny way Joe Rogan actually agreed
with me in in a certain way because he
he said at one point that he thinks
marriage is uh
is in his word silly
and that was my point by by discarding
the procreative aspect of marriage
it's fundamental purpose it's defining
features or one of its most important
defining features you make it useless
and pointless you make it yeah silly
you know I he defined it there marriage
is between two people who love each
other
you know I asked them well why two
people
no real reason for it to be just two
people and uh and why I mean how do you
define love and why do they need to love
each other and why do you need a piece
of paperwork
codifying the fact that you love someone
what's the point of that it just see it
it does seem that seems silly so that
version of marriage this as we want to
call expanded definition which you can't
really expand the definition you could
just destroy the definition you can
dismantle it but with that dismantled
definition you end up with something
that is silly
um and of course the reality for both of
us is that once you wade into these
Waters
on a topic like this it is in some ways
it's like a it's a lose-lose proposition
for Joe Rogan it is because even though
he's disagreeing with me
uh the very fact that he has me on the
show and that he's talking about this
and that he's letting me make my case
and he's taking my argument seriously
that's going to get him in trouble on
the left and it did
and for me on a topic like this in that
environment um obviously the left's
gonna hate me for what I say but who
cares about that
but also on the right there's going to
be a lot of Monday morning
quarterbacking no matter no matter how
you approach it like whatever argument
you make there's gonna be people say
well you should have made this argument
instead whatever approach you take well
you should have taken that approach
and uh and that's fine most most mostly
from people who have never
debated any of these issues in an
environment any more high stakes than
their living room or their Twitter page
and yet they are pretty sure they know
how they would have handled it fine
whatever
um
but I did want to address one thing
uh one criticism that I've heard from
people on the right for how I approach
this
and what I've heard from so from some
Christians is that I should have based
my argument on scripture on God now I
shouldn't have as I'm accused taken God
out of it
which I didn't of course anytime you're
talking about the true definition of
marriage you can't you can't you can't
take God out of that God is there
um but I should have explicitly said
that marriage is a man and a woman
because that's how God designed it and
that's what scripture declares that's
what they wanted me to say and I didn't
say that
but here's the problem
uh
to me it's quite obvious
to a secular audience arguing that
marriage is a certain way because the
Bible says so is not going to be
convincing or useful to them it's not
going to be a a useful argument in that
environment
because in order for the Bible says so
to be a compelling argument
uh you first need the other person in
the discussion to believe that there is
a God and that the Bible is his word so
those are two big things you need that
person to accept before because the
Bible says so is going to mean anything
to them
and I don't really see the point of
having an argument with someone or
trying to communicate with them if you
are not going to say things that are
meaningful to them
which means that if you want if you know
if you want to take it that direction
then that would mean that you need to
actually abandon the marriage
conversation completely and instead say
you know what let's first debate about
the existence of God and the validity of
the Bible
and then you you just you've you've
abandoned the marriage conversation
entirely so you can have this other
debate
and I think that would be a very
unfortunate decision and I do see
Christians do this sometimes on on topic
like marriage
when they're asked well you know why do
you believe in so-called traditional
marriage and very often I'll hear a
Christian say well because Bible because
God says so the Bible says so
and then it becomes a debate about the
existence of God
and I find that
an unfortunate strategy
because there is a defense of the nature
of marriage that you can make
without immediately throwing the Bible
verse at the person who doesn't care
what the Bible says
and the defense is exactly what I tried
to articulate there that marriage is a
certain thing that has a certain
definition which is based in its in in
the actual physical function of the
man-woman relationship
and that's also as we as we talked about
later on in the conversation that's also
why you find uh through history marriage
as an institution exists in every
culture in history
even cultures that are not Christian
now there might be some cultures where
they have polygamy or things like that
but the idea of marriage existing and to
be being between a man and a woman and
being a fundamentally procreative act
you find that all throughout history and
all over the world
because it's a matter of just natural
law it's it's you could find it in in
nature
and it's uh it's a in a lot of ways a
common sense thing
the man-woman relationship has this
capacity to create people and uh that
sets this relationship apart from any
other kind of relationship and it also
makes it important to society in ways
that other relationships simply aren't
it needs to be protected in ways that
other relationships simply don't because
of its capacity to create people and
because it is whether you like it or not
going to be the foundation of the family
and thereby the foundation of human
civilization
and you know the good thing is that if
if you can make that argument and of
course you're not going to convince
someone in the moment on something like
this most likely you're not going to
but you make the argument you make the
point
uh if you can
even get someone to take it seriously
and listen to you
you know you've brought them closer to
the truth
which means that you've also brought
them closer to God because God is truth
so that was the approach that which to
me seems clearly
uh the way to go in that kind of
environment well I hope you enjoyed that
clip from Matt wall show if you did be
sure to subscribe to this YouTube
channel and click the notification
button to get more content like this if
you want to watch or listen to the full
show head to dailywire.com And subscribe
today you can also listen to my podcast
on Spotify Apple podcast or wherever you
get your podcasts